I'm not going crazy you're going um I
think quarantine is making us all a
little crazy
that's Mila Kunis and Ashton Kutcher
chatting with Jimmy Fallon on Mondays
Tonight Show Home Edition and let's just
say they had a hard time keeping it
together Mila Kunis how are you doing
[Laughter]
the lovebirds played a game of voice
swap the rules are simple when Jimmy
asks me a question
Ashton answers and Mila moves her mouth
so it looks like she's answering and
vice-versa easy enough right
you would think Ashton Kutcher stay with
you how are you doing bud yeah just a
few seconds into the game and Mila was
hysterically laughing like legit crying
that my elbow was so kick you're not
even a P it was so carefully Ashton on
the other hand was killing it this is
like you know what my worst fear and I
said I'll never do it is SNL because of
this because I clearly enjoying laughter
and I was very hard time like like
holding you down
that's when Ashton reminded us of Jimmy
Fallon Saturday Night Live days he was
on the show from 1998 to 2004 and was
the ultimate giggler doing Jimmy on SNL
what this whole thing really went off
the rails and I bet you're thinking it
couldn't get any weirder think again boo
and my favorite thing to do is to just
go outside eat invite around
[Laughter]
anyway it wasn't all laugh attacks and
chest hair shaped like the bat-signal
you just can't make it up the two also
opened up about how they've been
educating their kids five-year-old
daughter Wyatt and three-year-old son
Dimitri it's a pretty creative strategy
the couple reached out to their friends
to zoom with their little ones and teach
them new things and it could be anything
from like making flower arrangements to
Architecture like anything and so that
gives us 20 minutes
um not parenting and also allows their
kids to have another type of interaction
they also talked about quarantine whine
which they started as a way to raise
money for charities and nonprofit groups
helping people amid the corona virus
pandemic I realized how when I selfishly
felt when I was able to donate and so in
a weird way just combine both my
favorite things drinking and thrown
eighty the couple launched their
quarantine themed wine last month and
Mila said they've already sold all of
their initial allotment 2,000 cases of
wine people in eight hours we were
shocked we're going to be very clearly
it's like yeah they raised over a
million dollars for Cove in nineteen
relief efforts and frankly I'm just mad
I didn't get in on the Pinot Noir hey
these are unprecedented times that we're
living in and unprecedented times call
for unprecedented drinking but more
drinking I like it preach these two
really are couple goals I haven't really
a great husband I really do Ashton and
Mila are clearly crushing it as actors
philanthropists mom and dad husband and
wife and here's what Mila told us in
2017 about balancing it all you're
running defense a little bit like you
have once got one the other ones got one
and it's okay it's one I thing becomes
three is when you're like then you're
just like playing offense I don't know
what you do at that point you're just
like scrambling to try to keep them all
in line
[Music]